thank you
[Music]
um hey stop looking man
you're right here well I'm just I'm
right here you're right here hey what's
article about hey what's article about
it did you cheat in high school all the
time okay let him present the article
based on that one glass you know what I
don't like this because because you're
putting it in front of me I like the
excitement it wasn't in front of you
you're just staring at it anyway you
know what did you read what did you read
on the screen I saw me nervous I thought
I don't you know what it's Anthony's job
and I want him to you know I don't want
to say his thing he's a very good guy
he's a good guy he's a great guy he was
a good guy just read this
just read that chest genius denies using
anal beads
to cheat
during tournament how do you cheat using
anal beads oh is that that Magnus there
is a thing where you know when you put
um you when you feel in your [ __ ]
they what is the what is the bead on
your left side of your ass the prostate
when you tap the prostate it sends you a
signal that makes you think before
you can transcend into a higher
intelligence
that's why guys are dumb it's nobody
[ __ ] transcended through their that's
why gay guys are smart did you know gay
couples are the highest earning couples
in America I believe that the prostate
smart and financially savvy so the
prostate is on the left that's what I
heard oh it's on the left oh I didn't
know I thought it would be like behind
my balls but yeah have you ever found
your process on the right other people
did yeah what other people found your
prostate when you when someone touch
your prostate I was smarter for a couple
days besides besides the smart part I'm
talking about the real stuff like did it
was it was it pretty good the prostates
did you come hard
I liked it a little bit
I want to try everything one time like
chess I would try and the anal
beast but I put my finger up there one
time yeah and he looked for it how far
did you get it did you see the did you
see the quadratic formula I did wait is
it like isn't it like when you're
scratching your own back versus when
somebody's scratching it for you or like
a massage no when I scratched my own bag
I could still jizz though oh okay wow
you know you're not just when you're
yeah so you guys like chess yeah I used
to be a part of the chess team I got
kicked out because this kid kept
cheating and so I [ __ ] arm swiped the
chess board and through the [ __ ]
table over and then the teacher was like
how was he cheating I was in third grade
see one of those [ __ ] where he
moves and then right when you're about
to move oh wait wait wait
you already knows the [ __ ] move I'm
trying to do or he would just do stupid
moves like you know how the [ __ ]
rook's supposed to move and all that he
would make up his own [ __ ] and I was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] table swipe
through and then when the teacher came I
was like this motherfucker's cheating
dude you're gonna be okay with that [ __ ]
and then I got kicked out for for
[ __ ] regulating the cheaters
I regulated the cheater and I got kicked
you still snitched bro a ball monitor
yeah true I shouldn't have snitched you
yeah you deserve death for that one dude
Trump's cheating I'm just like it's a
bigger crime on somebody the biggest
crime is when you go like this and then
she let go oh no no no no no no no as
soon as you let go once you lose contact
that's bigger climb the snitching yeah
that's the worst
and snitchy because he already know when
when he goes like this he sees that
you're gonna [ __ ] take his Pawn or
whatever and he's like oh I [ __ ] up
well let me do it this way yeah
yeah take backers just I just learned
that take backs is worse than snitching
but that's good the scale changes always
it's always so um this uh quote unquote
chess genius all right uh recently like
Jason over here just blew the whistle on
uh has been accused of cheating
um by use of anal bees can anybody guess
how that might have happened
and it's not the prostate thing it's uh
it's around the prostate thing all right
this this is this is what I think all
right
expensive chess pieces have pieces of
metal on their [ __ ] thing right so he
uses a [ __ ] magnetic anal bead to
navigate and move the chest pieces and
he's like I'm not doing that nothing and
then he's like
and then his [ __ ] like
this position changes yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna give that a slight almost really
really I mean it's definitely wrong but
I mean there's like oh let us guess and
get closer then I don't know enough
about Chess to give you let me give you
let me give you a couple more variables
let me give you a couple more variables
of the situation okay
uh there is this a kid named Hans Neiman
age 19. somehow managed to beat
five-time world champion player Magnus
Carlson oh wow Magnus is the [ __ ]
yeah he's a Jordan at the at the sync
field Cup Tournament in St Louis all
right so 19 year old kid out of nowhere
comes and beats five-time world champion
players so people are and they're all
like there's no way he's got to have
something in his ass check his ass yeah
then uh shortly after this quote unquote
uh lost by the five-time champion
Carlton the champion mysteriously
withdraws from the championship which
comes with a 350 000 overall prize fund
so then it's kind of like why why would
you withdraw from the company you're the
beer the goat you're the best dude
taking a Twitter he writes quote I've
withdrawn from the tournament I've
always enjoyed playing in the at St
Louis chess club and hope to be back in
the future but alongside the caption he
shares a cryptic clip of football
manager Jose Mourinho saying quote if I
speak I am in big trouble end quote okay
so he's got a little mystery behind it
he's The Whistleblower he wants he
ratted himself out no no this is the
five-time champion who got beat oh
withdrawing from it and then he like
leaves this little this little cryptic
kind of clip why is he withdrawing from
it
why would you why would you is that
Magna Carlson's anal beats no no but
he's embarrassed about it so he's using
this black mower every time he's about
to beat and goes remember these and
these oh [ __ ] they're not in they're not
in his ass he's just holding he's like
remember these I'm gonna tell the world
about these dude because he's like I'm
gonna [ __ ] ruin you right now
everyone thinks you're [ __ ] a hard
ass chest it's a black male [ __ ] yeah
cause it would ruin his reputation he's
a masculine chess player
he's wearing it as a necklace yeah like
like in his face he's like a 90s so
[ __ ] so it's like a band guy with the
with the beads all around his neck it's
like when Chong Lee puts the band down
on his knee yeah
yeah dude exactly and he's playing it
the whole time he's doing chess and [ __ ]
yeah and that's all that's the story
guys he's hearing it Russell I am really
interested how this could possibly be
what does anal tell us already we're
seven minutes in
right after this uh obviously after the
Tweet rumors of cheating soon started to
circulate especially after organizers of
the tournament ramped up security
measures and thoroughly checked Neiman
before his next game although they found
nothing on him but now you're probably
understanding where the anal beads come
you know is it is it is it because they
they did a metal digit program
like right around the ass and they're
like what's that what's in your pocket
sir if he's like I'm plugged up and
they're like what I'm plugged up so
following Neiman's win Canadian Grand
Masters Eric Hansen and Amman Hamilton
speculated in a twitch stream whether
he'd hidden a vibrating version of the
sex toy in his shoe to offer signals
indicating the Right Moves to oh wow and
it didn't take long for the idea to take
a life of its own on social media with
none other than the Tesla CEO Elon Musk
weighing in on the controversy
quote Talent hits a Target no one else
can hit genius hit a Target no one can
see that's true quote because it's in
your butt schopenhauer whoa that's a
really [ __ ] it is a genius thing to
do wait so how did they do it did one
person he wears those edible those uh
those little underwears that have a
vibrant yeah and then someone's in the
back just pushing buttons basically but
in anal bead format so he's literally
the speculation he's just going crazy
like it's not vibrating anal beings that
are in his ass that will vibrate when he
is in order for him to understand
whatever that language whatever the key
to like Morse [ __ ] so he's going like
this and then he's waiting and then he
goes
excuse me I am a genius wait so the
Champs you have to keep it on to
confirmary like this just do take back
he's like
oh yeah yeah
as long as you never lets go the pizza
right no thinking that's why he's so the
champ was signaling to the
which one was signaling cheater was
getting signals there's it's like a
person that's probably going through
like the most what's it called like the
statistically best moves to do yeah by
like looking at the live stream or
something like that basically or like
it's like your coaches in the corner
telling you don't make this move make
this move so someone was remote
vibrating on his [ __ ] that's the
speculation but what but why couldn't
they just play the game if they knew
better no because the difference is when
you're like let's say there's a team of
three or four of you and then you're
watching the live streams so you can see
and then you can play out every single
move and take it back or like computer
or you could just like a computer versus
like obviously if you're there in the
spot the second you let go you'll see
what's because they do have the machine
learning or the computer beat the best
chess player was it Magnus that they
that I think so he's the only he's like
the main [ __ ] guy and they beat him
and that was like a big deal like holy
[ __ ] that's how they caught him somebody
was trying to airdrop and it said
how come Magnus uh uh like pulled
himself out he knew about the cheating
and he or something he didn't want to
because he knew that the take backseats
is a worse crime that's snitching but
snitching is still bad
that Magnus is up the streets yeah he
knows the rules so he's like he's like I
want to say [ __ ] but I'll get in trouble
so I'm just gonna I'm not gonna go
commit a worship yeah cause I thought
Magnus would just be like being extorted
I think that was more true I think that
one's more he's like I think our
speculation that he was twirling the
anal beads that belong to Madness is the
right trail of evidence we should be
sniffing that's [ __ ] smart a little
Wi-Fi anal bead so the 19 year old
newcomer has since addressed the
accusations in a lengthy interview
speaking in a five-hour stream posted on
St Louis chess club he admitted to
cheating in online games when he was a
young team which he called quote an
absolute ridiculous mistake Neiman went
on to say that never in his life has he
cheated in an over the board game AKA in
real life and never in an online
tournament for prize money other than
when he was 12 years old so it's all
still speculation oh so the anal bead
stuff is they didn't catch him they just
made it up people just made it up you
got anal beads in your shoe or some [ __ ]
apparently there's been some version of
like this vibrating sex toy hidden
somewhere that like can communicate
therefore there's like you know an
understood kind of conspiracy if there's
a way to cheat that's how people but if
if you if you uh add that to the
security had to check him before his
next round and found nothing on him then
I think the imagination of like it's got
to be in his ass well what if he's just
monetizing his stream he's not really
using it to cheat you know like you can
donate money and make the [ __ ] thing
vibrate yeah yeah oh guys guys please
don't oh guys please that's a big money
I'm trying to play ooh I love those
videos those are my favorite videos yeah
that's what I watch
foreign